je suis sûr tu t'es jamais confessé toi
non
tu veux commencer avec moi ce soir je
sais pas si c'est marrant tu es pas en
soutane et rien
chercher alors on ne veut pas dire avec
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Lio est-ce que tu es favorable à
l'avortement moi je me suis fait avorter
plein de fois j'ai eu un enfant je sais
pas si je me ferais avorter encore avec
la même facilité disons mais mais je
trouve que c'est un droit inaltérable la
peine de mort je suis contre je suis
contrat 400 000% quand une société aura
prouvé qu'elle a le bien fondé de juger
on reparlera des choses d'ailleurs ce
jour-là il y aura plus besoin de peine
de mort parce qu'il y aura plus de lit
aussi grave pour ça est-ce que tu es
pour la légalisation des drogues douces
oui
je suis pour la légalisation et
l'information de tout ce qui nous fait
du bien
quels sont tes tabous
tu as dit une fois que tes héros
préférés étaient Jésus-Christ et
Pénélope est-ce que pour Jésus-Christ tu
peux nous expliquer
mais c'est très c'est très évident à
comprendre c'était un vrai
révolutionnaire Jésus-Christ je dis en
fait le vrai martyre c'est Judas parce
que Jésus l'alboro et Judas lui il est
finalement jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
il a le mauvais rôle c'est lui le vrai
martyre mais oui on peut très très bien
voir ça comme ça ce qui pouvait encore
qu'il n'y a pas
d'ombre s'il n'y a pas de lumière et
qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans la mort bien
entendu que Judas était quand même la
pierre d'achoppement de la possibilité
de sacrifice du Christ qui donc en étant
martyr reste un symbole pour des
générations et des générations et des
millénaires bien entendu que Judas et
quelqu'un qui est un symbole tout aussi
puissant et que l'Inde devait révéler
l'autre
retour d'un voyage aux Indes tu avais
découvert le bouddhisme et tu disais que
le bouddhisme répondait à toutes les
questions qu'on se pose est-ce que tu
crois toujours ça aujourd'hui oui ça
permet de répondre à toutes les
questions maintenant encore faut-il
pouvoir les mettre en acte parce que ce
compense est une chose se compense n'a
aucune valeur si on n'arrive pas à
l'application
si tu avais un seul mot à dire à ta
fille un seul message un seul conseil à
lui donner ça serait quoi soit toi
vie parce que tant que tu as envie tu es
envie et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu